build it draw it playing Vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people
this is bdp building estonian designer
pavel Sidorenko repurposes old vinyl
records into wall clocks the series is
called revine 'el and he wants to reduce
the waste of useful materials as well as
decrease the consumption of new
materials some of his designs include
cityscapes animals human interaction and
inanimate objects
Alvaro Casa Nellie created these robotic
Japanese garden lamps for an exhibition
in Tokyo they're able to sense other
objects so they don't step on plants or
run into anything in the garden and they
can be controlled with a smart device
his hope is to one day have a garden
that takes care of itself in the absence
of humans designer eco gang made these
autonomous drawing machines out of
everyday objects paired with different
media including a hand mixer using
watercolor a wind-up clock using pencil
led and a Walkman using charcoal dust
and Yellin makes 3d collages by encasing
objects in two layers of glass he uses
pieces he finds on the street clippings
computer-generated images acrylic and
glass to create the sculptures like this
massive piece that weighs 12 tons and is
forty six point five inches tall 69
inches long and 27 inches deep and his
latest series is called psycho
geography's draw high-voltage is a
project by philip david stern's that
merges electronics with photography he
produces images by applying 15,000 volts
of electricity to instant color film
that's about a thousand times the
strength of a car battery
it creates an organic pattern and shows
off the ability of instant film beyond
its typical use of capturing the world
around us Brant pan-ma is a giant mural
using only latex paint and a black
sharpie
it took artist Sean Sullivan seven
months to get to the point where he
finally consented it done partly because
he exceeded his original timeline for
the piece by four months now for when
the lights go out to an art showcase
featuring glow in the
our prince a shop is a production
company that creates giant scale
graffiti murals street art and urban
aesthetics they have a large collection
of artists that work for both commercial
and private clients to make murals for
interiors and exteriors as well as
custom pieces finally below to check out
the full video playing classic pianist
Yoshiki performed a piano duel with a
hologram of himself live at the 2014
South by Southwest
reading my body created by Dimitri
mazzaroth as a sound controller that
detects ink on your skin to play your
tattoos the Georgia Tech Center for
music technology created this robotic
drumming prosthesis used here by Jason
Barnes
and finally self song by fan Farlow is a
music video created by you and Jones
Morris using old science journals and
encyclopedias
Oh
submit your bidipis as a personal
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at facebook.com slash
Vsauce t wo
click here listen to a brand new
installment of bdp radio music created
and submitted by you guys also check out
your bidipi an entire video dedicated to
only your creations and as always thanks
for watching